but everyone loves lucy
the story of this great white is the
classic finding nemo tale
but about 2 000 pounds heavier
when divers spotted lucy back in 2008
her distinctive tail wound looked fresh
and she seemed in desperate need of a
good meal
a damaged cattle fin puts a shark's life
in danger
it's crucial for propelling a shark
through water
lucy's tail deformity could be from
fighting with another shark when she was
younger
and lucy's not only survived she's
thrived she did it by modifying the way
she swims
to sway a little more than the average
grade white
[Music]
and now lucy's adoring public keeps an
eye out for her signature floppy fin
and her unique swagger
unlike other female great whites lucy
returns to guadalupe island
every year and that is because she has
not given birth yet
if she did she'd be gone at least 12 to
18 months
because that's how long a sharp
pregnancy lasts
fans don't know for sure why lucy's
still not a mom
it could be that male sharks are turned
off by her misshapen fin
or maybe lucy hasn't yet met zapata
the most famous and recognizable male
great white of guadalupe island
this tough guy's a 14-footer who's mixed
it up with other apex predators
and has the battle scars to prove it
sapada is a very large shark to sustain
the wounds
it received the attacking shark must
have been
very large possibly 18 or 20 feet in
length
he might not play well with other sharks
but luckily unlike bullet
zapata actually enjoys hanging out with
people
that's my favorite shark right there
[Music]
scarborough at an intimidating 18 feet
long
isn't just one of the most massive
sharks at guadalupe island
she's one of the biggest great whites in
the world
but like all sharks no one will know for
sure how old she is
until after she dies one of the ways to
determine the age of a shark
is by dissecting it if we cut through a
vertebra
we can see rings similar to those
of a tree showing annual growth
she got her nautically themed name
because of scars on the right
or starboard side of her body
when sharks engage in head-to-head
combat they can do incredible damage to
each other
which is what happened to scarborough
but sharks have amazing healing
abilities
scarborough shows up at guadalupe every
other year
and the next time you see her many of
her scars
might be gone
bullet
lucy
zapata
and scarborough
four sharks whose physical flaws grabbed
our attention
and helped make them famous
[Music]
you